[Music]  to look over the horizon and wonder  what's there it's part of what makes us  human even before we were fully human  some 2 million years ago our early  ancestors first left Africa for Asia  long before the age of European  exploration ancient Polynesians in  canoes spread throughout the vast  Pacific Phoenicians mastered the  Mediterranean and Vikings crossed the  Atlantic 500 years ago in 1519 Magellan  set forth on the first successful voyage  to circumnavigate the entire globe and  in the 20th century humans reached the  planets highest peaks and its distant  poles with the invention of the airplane  a new era of exploration was launched  and about a generation after Limburg  flew the Atlantic we reached outer space  and a vast new frontier it was 50 years  ago this summer that Apollo 11 emerged  from a ball of fire streaking towards  the moon with three men on board Neil  Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and Michael  Collins  [Music]  you  [Music]